depuis 1974 cette maison est dédié à
jeanne d'arc ici aujourd'hui nous avons
pu avoir un éclairage sur ce personnage
historique dont on parle beaucoup mais
dont finalement on ne sait pas grand
chose c'est dans cette maison quasiment
un centre de recherche sur jeanne d'arc
qu'on a trouvé des réponses à nos
questions
je vous laisse regarder le reportage et
on se retrouve juste après au nom du
seigneur a même commence le procès en
cause deux fois contre une femme décédée
madame jeanne vulgairement dit la
pucelle sur ces reproductions des cris
du xvème siècle le procès de jeanne
d'arc et des lettres qui redonne vie
l'espace de quelques instants à la
pucelle d'orléans faut savoir que c'est
par jeanne qui écrit ces lettres c'est
un secrétaire et qu'elles mêmes signes
savait pas écrire donc elle dessine sa
signature
et là il ya un élément qui est
intéressant pour la prononciation de
jeanne parce que le secrétaire a écrit
ce qu'on le ce qu'il a entendu
c'est à dire vous aurez bientôt
nouvelles dont vous serez bien choix you
il a réfléchi il a barré choix you et il
a écrit joyeux donc jeanne d'arc
prononcent pas joyeux elle prononce
choix you avec sa cette indication et
d'autre on sait que par exemple n'aurait
pas dit bonjour je m'appelle jeanne
d'arc elle leur a dit bonjour shdm ap li
shan taille la maison de jeanne d'arc
un lieu pour répondre aux questions des
visiteurs car son histoire est méconnue
on en parle beaucoup à orléans et c'est
pour ça du coup que je voulais venir
dans cette ville parce que c'est vrai
que c'est super intéressant la ville est
belle en plus on va essayer de découvrir
à la fois sa vie 1
les lieux aussi un peu historique et
tous à relier sur la même vivre au sein
de l'établissement un documentaire
retrace les étapes de la vie de sept
dont rémoise jeunes lecteurs de sony
trois ans plus tard la guerre de son
temps de prendre celle qui libère
orléans des anglais en 1429 est
représentée par des statues de plâtre
jeanne d'arc arrêtés accusés d'hérésie
et la pucelle en armure une reproduction
qui a permis la construction de celle de
l'hôtel groslot ancien hôtel de ville
d'orléans un portrait au plus proche de
sa vie et de son époque pour cette
figure majeure de l'histoire de france
dont la trace est partout présente à
orléans
alors nous revoici je suis en compagnie
d'olivier docteur en histoire et
responsable scientifique de la maison
jeanne d'arc depuis presque trente ans
bonjour d'hier
alors olivier à quel moment jeanne d'arc
est elle entrée dans l'histoire de
france
et bien tout de suite des 429
d'abord parce que c'est une jeune fille
très charismatique elle a beaucoup
marqué ses contemporains par son action
et qu'elle a été tout de suite présenté
comme un ange envoyé par dieu pour
prouver que dieu aimait particulièrement
les la france est elle reste sous cet
aspect dans la littérature jusqu'au
moment de la révolution française il ya
pratiquement ou deux livres publiés
chaque année jusqu'au moment de la
révolution et vers 1750 en plus elle
devient en quelque sorte la
représentante de la france avant que son
image ne devienne serve de modèle pour
l'image de marianne donc elle est tout
de suite dans le bain et elle représente
la france tout de suite
et justement c'est une représentante de
la france parce que elle est aussi
célèbre à l'étranger beaucoup
l'utilisent comme figure mais de quelle
manière ils utilisent justement à
l'étranger alors dès 1800 elle apparaît
dans une pièce de théâtre de friedrich
von schiller qui écrit une pièce qui
s'appelle guillaume fra aux points d'eau
reliant et qui est adapté à l'opéra par
verdi par tchaïkovski et donc elle passe
en italie en russie un site 8 et ses
chimères qui lui donne
l'aspect qu'elles gardent encore de nos
jours de symbole de l'unité nationale on
va dire et aussi peut-être surtout de
résistance à l'envahisseur de résistante
à l'oppression